thank you
good afternoon and welcome to this
performance governance nordic committee
meeting on thursday the 30th of july
2020. my name is councillor elaine
bamford
and i'm chairman of this committee
this meeting is held under new
regulations which came
into effect on the 4th of april in
response to the covid
19 situation and there are just a few
housekeeping issues to run through
first of all please could i ask everyone
present in this meeting to ensure your
microphone remains muted
and your video feed off when not
addressing the committee
this will reduce background noises and
avoid any unintentional disturbances
this meeting is being hosted remotely
streamed live
and recorded and by being present in the
meeting you are giving your consent to
being recorded
members and offices during each item
please use the chat
function of the meeting to indicate if
you wish to speak
i would then invite you at the
appropriate time
members are reminded that apart from
indicating you wish to speak or that you
have to leave the meeting
the track function should not be used
for
asking questions or for any other
purpose
please do not use the raise hand
function as this
is not available on all members devices
when speaking and referring to the
agenda papers please ensure you
reference a page or paragraph number
and last if members need to leave the
meeting at any point please do make this
known
and use the chat function to signify
that you need to leave the meeting
and now may i ask officers taking part
in the meeting to introduce themselves
starting with miss cardi
good afternoon um i am annette cardy i
am the resources specialist services
manager
thank you mr clark
good afternoon my name is spencer clark
and i'm the community safety manager at
modern district council
thank you mr dodson good afternoon paul
dodson director of strategy performance
and governance
thank you miss donnelly
we don't seem to have emma just quite
yet cancer
thank you mr holmes
good afternoon members richard holmes
director of service delivery
ms hughes good afternoon members
cheryl hughes programs performance and
governance manager
mr leslie afternoon
chris leslie director of resources
thank you have we got mr rubens
not yet thank you mr wisdom
uh good afternoon members uh name's
craig we've done on the
external order partner from deloitte
thank you now i'm not sure if i'll
pronounce this
surname correctly it's a new member of
staff i believe
miss sangee
external auditor uh external audit
manager
for modern district council thank you
very much
and berna casey
yes good afternoon members burn uh chair
to the sorry
talk to the meeting this afternoon thank
you any other officers that are present
have we got mr donnelly or
uh mr rubin checked please uh not
not yet chairman yeah let's
good afternoon members
okay thank you anyone else
uh so okay berna please can we carry out
a roll call of members to confirm who's
in attendance
thank you yes chairman i will
take you in alphabetical order council
bamford
well i'm obviously president thank you
nabeel
councillor beale
council channel
hello i'm present
uh present and correct thank you
president
presents
present pastor jarvis
present thank you berna keys
council of keys
counselor none
yes here bernard
stamp
present burner thank you castle stills
present burner pastor swain
yes presents council mrs thompson
present um i believe council keys may
well be working so
could you put him for apologies please
thank you
thank you chairman could any other
members who are in attendance please
introduce themselves now
uh castle maze malden north
thank you any other members
could i just uh give councillor bill's
apologies i've just spoken to him he's
been unavoidably detained
thank you very much
members well we'll move on to the next
agenda item then which is um
apologies for absence um
have we got any apologies bernard take
it um
counselor keys and be all um we need to
record
yes and cancer schemes chairman
i've just received an email from mr
rubens to say that both himself and miss
donnelly are having difficulties joining
the meeting even though we had no
problems
earlier on so perhaps you could take
the um second sorry item seven and i
will organize
for them to join the meeting later okay
thank you we'll see what happens okay so
we'll go to
the minutes of the 25th of june
um which i found on pages five to
fourteen
these are to see if they are true and
accurate
record so um
do you want me to go through each one in
turn
each page or is everyone happy to take
them on on block
i have got one correction on page five
please
chairman the first page okay cancel
i think uh sorry i'll just have to uh
i'll have to change over to
to uh yes on page five the last
paragraph
it starts the director of resources on
the second line down it's the 31st of my
there should be an a there
on the second line on the website on 30.
oh i say yes it says my instead of may
okay that's fair enough thank you very
much for that
being very observant of you um okay
members so i'll run through it then so
it's page six
page seven page eight
page nine page ten
page eleven page twelve
page thirteen and page fourteen
agreed so we're happy to take those yeah
great
good
so i need just need a seconder please
yes
counselor happy district okay thank you
council head
um so we don't need to take a vote
enough because we've just
we've agreed those on block so now we
move on to
declarations of interest and i'll read
this out to disclose the existence and
nature of any disclosable pecuniary
interests or pecuniary interests or
non-pecuniary interests
relating to items of business on the
agenda having regards to paragraphs
six to eight inclusive of the code of
conduct from members
and members are reminded that they are
also required to disclose any such
interest
as soon as they become aware should the
needs need a rise throughout the meeting
so if any member has an interest to
declare please use the chat function
to indicate that you um wish to speak
bernar have we got anyone yes councillor
channel
chairman that's a channel
uh thank you madam chairman i will
declare non-pecuniary in that i'm also a
member of essex county council
because some of the reports refer to the
community safety partnership
the rag um and other areas but any other
area
in the agenda that might link in any way
with essex or any
you know things we share in partnership
um
i'm going to cover myself with that
declaration chairman thank you
thank you councillor anyone else berna
yes councillor durham channel
you chairman um also uh
also a non-cunary interest as a member
of ethics county council
for much the same reason as has been
disclosed by councillor mrs chana thank
you
thank you council durham any other
members bernard
no chairman that's it okay so we move on
to
public participation um
i don't think we've got any members of
the public um that
that have sent in any submissions so
we'll move on to
the next item now that is internal audit
reports and i don't think we've got
anyone
yet have we berna um no they have been
sent the invite again both emma and greg
and we're just waiting for them to join
us okay
i've put a message in the meeting chat
with nothing
they haven't appeared yet so we'll move
on then
we'll come back to that item and we'll
move on to
agenda item seven which is the external
audit
audit planning report to the 31st of
march
2020 um on pages 53-76
so we've got um craig wisdom i believe
um to present this report
thank you craig so again good afternoon
um so you're having that in the papers
my old plan
uh which would normally have come to an
earlier meeting but but that has been
that was impacted by
october 19. so um i'll
i'll go through that report but i'll
also give you a quick update on where we
are with the audit itself which is
currently in
in progress so just starting with the
external audit plan
um chair if i may i will assume that the
document is read
but i now talk to pages 57 and pages 58
of the pack um so just starting off with
the scope of our audit the scope of our
which is in line
with last year and just a reminder we
i carry out my auditor in accordance
with the requirements of the code of
order practice which says that
and with guidance from the national
order office
the key risk areas of and the areas of
focus this year were
management override of controls just to
be clear this is an assumed risk
under international watching standards
and one that we have to carry out
on every audit that we do the focus of
our work
is key areas of estimate judgment
and we also look for inappropriate
journal entries and things like that
second key risk area uh or area of focus
is the valuation of property clients and
equipment
um we focus on this because there's
there's a lot of judgment involved
um you get an external evaluation
performed and there's there's a lot of
judgments involved
in that um in the current year there is
also additional complexity because of
the impact of curve 19 and the impact
that that has had on
the valuations of assets as of the 31st
of march
um so what this has done is led to your
valuer including a material uncertainty
clause
in the value in the valuation so just to
be clear this isn't to say that they
think that the evaluation is wrong they
they are comfortable providing
evaluation
they are just flagging though that there
is an increased
uncertainty associated with that so
that is disclosed in your accounts and
i'll also refer to that in my opinion
but a couple of key things to note on
that are one um
it's the the material uncertainty uh
inclusion by your valuer is is common
across
um public sector and valuations of this
type so that's normal
and the second thing is just now when i
said i were referred to
that disclosure in my opinion that's not
a qualification or a modification of my
of my opinions just just to be clear
that's not me modifying or qualifying
i'm just drawing attention to it so that
was the second area of
of um focus and the third is is pension
liabilities
uh where we focus on uh the key
assumptions that go into the actuarial
evaluation along with the
evaluation of uh the supporting uh
assets that bring you back down to the
net liability
so those are the key areas of focus um
unsurprisingly covert has had an impact
on the audit as well uh both in terms of
the accounts themselves but also in
terms of the delivery of the audit uh
in terms of the accounts the key impacts
uh really are around you know the
council has had to include will have to
include
additional narrative reporting uh around
covert and certainly the risks around
that
they'll also need to include additional
disclosures around
key risks and uncertainties uh as well
the second area here is as i've just
said around impact of on property plants
and equipment
and investment properties as well so
as i say there is there is greater
judgment
involved in this year's valuation of
those assets
the third area is pension so you'll see
just
i'm starting to see the correlation
between my areas of focus and the areas
that are impacted as well
but the third area is the impact on the
pension fund um
investments uh again because
unfortunately 31st of march was was just
as everything was
was um was was kicking off on code that
said there was a lot of uncertainty in
the markets and around the asset
valuations at that stage
i think the the fourth area i'd probably
pull out um
is um the looking at the assets on the
balance sheet in particular
the bad debt um provision that's
associated with
the debtors um because we do have to go
with councilors have to consider whether
there is an increased risk of poor debt
recovery as a result of that so
those are probably the three so those
are probably the four key areas
of an impact on the accounts but there
are others but
but um sort of less of an impact um on
the delivery side of the audit uh we
have had to deliver
europe remotely and we've worked
with officers to make sure that that is
as efficient as possible
we we do have tools and technology and
project and project management
software that allows us to manage that
remotely so
actually at the end of the day whilst
it's not um whilst there are
it is a little bit harder to do it um we
are able to deliver
to deliver that and i will be able to to
complete my audit um completely remotely
this year
um that's all i wanted to say on the
order plan
um but if i could i'll just continue
with a quick update of where we are on
the delivery of the audit itself um
you'll hopefully be pleased to hear that
you know whilst there still have been
some challenges certainly um
the audit has been significantly better
um this year
uh which i think is a which is a good
reflection on the team and and the
progress that they've made
um but i also think it's a it's a good
reflection given the additional
challenges that that team have had to
face
um through this year in process um given
given the covert 19 impact and remote
working for themselves so
i think um i think the fact that uh you
know
where i am in the stage of the order
this this year
is actually uh probably quite well
advanced compared to a number of other
clients as well as
other clients across our deloitte
portfolio so i do think the betas are
positive or should be taken as a
positive reflection on the team but
as i say they have responded in my view
really positively to recommendations
that we made last year
and there's been that and it's been a
big step forward which is very good news
um just in terms of the status we are
substantially
um substantial way through the audit and
we're looking to close down the
remaining areas over the uh over the
next
two to three to three weeks so
with smooth sailing we're hoping hoping
to be there or there about by the end of
uh by the end of august
um so yeah i think that's um that's
good news or a good new token um
gentlemen that's i'll stop there
and i'm happy to take questions either
on the plan itself
or certainly on the delivery of yours as
well
thank you very much mr wisdom and thank
you for your comments about the staff
they have worked very hard and uh under
difficult circumstances and uh
i think we all appreciate that so thank
you now
um members before we move on um
to questions which um i'd ask you use
the chat function if you want to ask
a question um just to remind you the
recommendation
is just to note the report
but i will tell you that regarding the
fees which you will notice
have been mentioned in the report
we are having a meeting um myself and
the vice chairman
with mr wisdom and um our director chris
leslie
director of resources tomorrow just to
discuss
the fees um so um if you have a question
on that i think we
will probably address that tomorrow um
so can i move to questions then please
members berna have we got anyone that
wants to ask
um a question no chairman just
harker commenting that it's for noting
oh uh sorry counselor swain has now um
said he'd like to ask a question okay
councillor swain
um think about it it's just
right at the end of the report deloitte
say that this report is confidential
is this a problem
uh mr wisdom do you want to comment on
that
please i think you're muted at the
moment
page 75. that's right if i get off me
apologies for that so the illusive
button um
uh sorry counselor though
it's not a problem um my i should have
amended that
um i'm aware that this report is being
as part of a public pack
um and therefore it's most definitely
not and
not not confidential though
well well spotted cancer swain um
so any other members want to raise
anything on this report
which is for noting
no one else no not at the moment german
okay thank you
thank you sorry noted
so i just need someone to second the
recommendation so what's that counselor
swain
yeah thank you
so that's accepted then we noted that
thank you very much members
um so we move have we got
um the internal auditors at all yet yes
we have we've got both
we've got andrew robins and emma
donnelly okay lovely
um so we'll go back then
um i think most members know emma
donnelly
and greg rubin so i don't think we need
to introduce them again
so we're going back then members to item
six on the agenda which was the internal
audit reports
um there are three progress community
safety and workforce management
um we also have offices as well
on um the community safety workforce
management which
um will go to after
the auditors have presented the reports
so um is ms donnelly going to present
all of them or greg
your greg rubins i believe miss donnelly
miss donnelly okay thank you well miss
donnelly then please
actually if you don't mind i'm sorry
okay i'll start i was just going to
introduce them and then and over to miss
donnelly
and so i was just going to say in terms
of progress overall we
are now making up some of the lost
ground that happened as a result of the
delays through covid
um so we've issued we've got two reports
coming today
that have been finalized from 1920. the
corporate governance audit i know
members are interested in that one we've
just received um responses from officers
to that so that will be finalized
um over the next couple of days and that
will come to the next
uh meeting of your committee um
and the flooding audit is just about to
uh start in terms of the scoping
so we are making good headway and a
number of audits for 2020 21 have also
started
as the progress report makes clear and
we've also got within a progress report
a few changes we've agreed
with officers to the audit plan they're
just practical changes in terms of
uh issues that we think need to be
looked at um
more quickly so there's the fraud work
as members are aware
um that we've been asked to do to um uh
follow up from the fraud risk assessment
um and also um the work against the sit
for code of practice on financial
management so
both those audits are important so we've
made some tweaks to the plan
to include those so that's all i was
going to say on general progress but
obviously
um emma donnelly will present the two
reports unless there's any questions at
this stage
okay thank you very much mr rubens
members have we
uh berna have we got anyone that wants
us to
raise the question on internal audit
progress
no john okay thank you um so
um
we move on to community safety audit ms
donnelly
um sorry chairman it's uh councillor
heard here
sorry yeah i i have a question although
i'll wait i'll wait for it to be
presented but i don't seem to have a
chat
function uh just on the ipad so i've
raised my hand
okay um so this is on community safety
council heard is it
uh it's on the first part of the report
i'm i'm sorry i'm having to go between
one script
the two screens uh this is on the
summary of the work
so it's on the progress report that greg
rubins has just um
talked about yes so if you'd like to
raise your point now then
if it's on right i've got
three questions if i may the first one
uh is on page 19
and it talks about the following audits
that have been finalized one of them is
a workforce management
uh so that has been finalized
and then in the next row on the 2021
i see the workforce management again
is being raised in august 2020
so i wanted to know why
why is this audit being looked at so
soon
that was my first question the next one
is on page uh page 20
which talks about the main financial
systems
increase to 25 days
i'd like to know what evidence there is
for this
to have been added and
finally on page 22
uh there are some
uh audits i think the corporate plan
and priorities uh is being removed i'm
not quite sure i think it's being
removed
if it is can i know why that is please
thank you thank you mr rubins would you
like to ask yes i'll certainly try i
mean i think in terms of workforce
um we look at different elements of
workforce obviously hr and workforce is
is a is a risky area an important area
for the council
so we focused on i think recruitment um
uh for 1920 and there'll be a different
focus for 2021.
i'm not sure if we've agreed that yet
perhaps emma donnelly will will come in
if
if she knows any more but i think those
discussions are still happening um
all right we're just agreeing in the
scope on which what part we'll look at
this year
so that's why yeah different area um
so and on main financial systems and
we've increased it slightly i think it's
only by five days
but it's it's for a grant claim that
we've been asked to do
so um you know we obviously need some
more days to be able to do that
um and on the corporate plan i mean i
think that was just seen as not
particularly urgent at this moment in
time uh again emma i don't know if
you've got anything to add to that
um that was just part of the um the
the the rearranging and audits to kind
of make up for
obviously the changes this year because
of covet i think
well if i could just come back on that
chairman i'm very surprised that uh that
the priorities
uh are being put to one side i mean
we should be the the audits should be
bribed priority and i'm very surprised
that that's
been given a um a back seat
[Music]
um have we got any officers that want to
come in on
commenting on that oh mr leslie yes if i
could
thank you madam chairman yeah with the
priorities
um side of it if i perhaps um talk to
that one
first um it's felt that um
with the covert 19 and the actual uh
look at the
current priorities of the council
there's a bit of work going on around
that
to look at that that's taking place so
it's felt that actually an audit at this
time wouldn't really be beneficial
because there's already some internal
work going on around that so it's
actually better to wait until that
internal work's been done
and then we can actually have the audit
on that side so it's a case of timing
around that and with the main financial
systems
as mr rubens has said it is an increase
of five days
but uh that's a very important area at
the moment with uh coping 19 and the
financial implications
and also we're coming in to a change in
uh
international financial reporting
standards in one particular area
and that's potentially something we
could uh we could have
internal audits support on i think
they'll be very very useful
so that's why there's been some changes
within those areas
thank you mr leslie well just to clarify
then because
on this page 20
it says removal from the plan to
facilitate the above
audit so we've got removal of corporate
plan and priorities
and removal of policy review and then
you've added
um sifa
fm code prep preparedness
and fraud work um so
what you're saying is those two are
added because we need to do those
sooner than dealing with what was
originally on the plan
so the corporate plan and policy review
will come in again
next to next time then not
during this period yeah that's right
yeah i mean it will certainly be
in our proposals for the plan next year
again obviously we'll have to go through
a prioritization
process but those two i think the
timeliness of those would be better next
year
okay thank you thank you does that
answer your questions counselor heard
uh yes thank you very much okay thank
you then
right so we'll go on then to
donnelly sorry chairman councillors uh
swain and stamp have a question
oh i'm sorry sorry so this is on inter
progress report yes
that's the swain thank you very much yes
on page 22 it's partly
what mr movement has just talked about
these um audits of
policy review and corporate plan
priorities
um and now i see why they're now blanks
on the report
but my question was really what exactly
does um
an audit of those fields cover
[Music]
i mean i think obviously both of them
would have been scoped
with officers to get to you know uh
detail that but it but in broad terms a
corporate plan and priorities audit
would look at how you set your
uh plan and your priorities have you had
a you know a good process in place has
it been signed off
appropriately and have you set up
measures to be able to see how you're
going to achieve those priorities so
are there key performance indicators and
again a process to be able to
monitor those if we're talking about
policies we normally would be looking
again at
what the adequacy of your process for
ensuring that
you've got a comprehensive list of all
policies that need to be updated
are they being updated on a regular
basis is there appropriate member
or officer approval of those policies so
that that in very broad terms that's
what the audits would do
thank you um a councillor stamp
oh yes chairman just for clarity for me
please if that's okay
who actually makes these decisions then
to remove the corporate plan
and priorities and policy review is it
the officers on their own or is it the
offices
and leaders or different committees what
who actually then arrives to make that
decision
that those um things that need to be
looked at or audited have
have changed or fallen back
yeah it's a process that we have with
officers obviously the section 151
officer
as the main contact to discuss and agree
changes to the plan
but ultimately of course it goes to this
committee for approval so
um you have the ultimate say if you're
not uh happy with that proposal but we
think it's
sensible we wouldn't if we thought an
area needed to be audited urgently or
was a high risk we would
of course you know under our objective
independent standards we would insist on
still doing that we don't think that
applies here we're comfortable with the
changes but obviously you as members
need to be comfortable with that as well
chairman can i ask the question then to
mr leslie has he made the decision with
his team
or is it to do with any councillors or
the leadership team as well i'm just
trying to ascertain
who has actually made that decision and
i understand you've said the reason why
i'm not disputing that i want to know
how you've reached
that decision thank you mr leslie yeah
thank you
yes so the process we adopted um because
of covet 19 obviously had quite a
significant impact on the time
frames of these audits because they
weren't able to get started quite as
quickly as we would like we had a
discussion with the
extended leadership team around the area
areas
and looking at a review of the existing
audit plan and seeing what timings and
changes need to be made
so that's the discussion that took place
as an extended leadership team looking
at the priorities and looking at the
achievability of the audit plan and then
coming up
with a revised plan which we felt hit
the priorities and also was achievable
in the time frame
and then obviously write the report and
take it to yourselves uh for
approval thank you
councillor stamp are you happy with that
response
yes it's quite clear thank you it was it
wasn't just uh the officers it was
certain membership of the leadership
team thank you very much
okay thank you so any more members
sorry uh commander jarvis council jarvis
council jarvis
councillor jarvis ah here we go yep
sorry about that
in connection yes i think um there's
some good observations
have been made there by councillors and
um
i think we've heard that explanation uh
but there was a danger that we would
have
just skirted over that without spotting
it so i think we probably should ask
officers where decisions like that are
made
um during these times in particular
where there's a sort of caviar special
measures group perhaps to put a
statement
clearly in this report where decisions
are being made
to substitute one audit for another
perhaps with a short explanation much
along the lines that we've been given
um uh by officer leslie uh i think
that's
that would be the sort of thing i would
would want to be highlighted to me
rather than have to sort of spot it um
if that's okay chairman yes thank you
very much yes i take your point on that
um and i'm sure the auditors will take
that
on board for future reports um
counselor her did you want to come back
with something sorry
chairman cancer fluker wanted to speak
next and then councillor heard with
monsters okay thank you councillor
yeah thank you chairman and good
afternoon to you um i wonder if mr mr
lazy just said the extended leadership
team but that
doesn't involve members so perhaps you'd
like to just
uh confirm that because i think he's
referring to the
tier 2 managers and
best of my knowledge is these uh issues
have never been discussed with img and
certainly not discussed with me but i
think
the extended leadership team means the
tier two managers perhaps mr leslie
could confirm that
okay thank you mr leslie yeah that's
correct the extended leadership
team involves the tier two managers and
clt members
okay thank you councillor heard sorry
chairman just to come back
sorry yeah i'm sorry to interrupt but so
clearly that doesn't involve members and
i hope that helps you and counsellor
jarvis with taking this forward thank
you okay
thank you so councillor her did you want
to raise something further
well i i wanted to to raise that very
point but
just looking back on the on the audi
areas that they're looking at
i see that we've got 15 days on
knowledge management and transfer
uh i'm not quite sure what that means
but it it appears to me to be on a lower
priority than the corporate plan
and priorities uh that's why i say there
hasn't there hasn't been that member
involvement
thank you um mr leslie do you
could you comment on that or would that
be mr rubin's
i know i'm happy to comment uh on that
um
obviously given the explanation for the
policy
side of it um if members want to make
any uh recommendations at this stage of
course
that's welcome um it's part of the
committee process is that we produce our
recommendations
um as the officers and take it to
yourself uh as members
to to discuss and i think if you wanted
to think of
a uh different forum um before it came
here we're going to have that
conversation
but with regards to this obviously there
are two changes
to to the plan um for yourselves to look
through so happy to take those comments
on board
um so miss um sorry um
counselor heard you mention knowledge
something where was this
yes uh i i just wonder if you could help
me knowledge management and transfer
15 days to be spent we want to know what
that
is exactly and how it relates to
possibly corporate plan or policy
how it how it uh
the priority of it you know how how much
more important it is
okay um mr leslie could you comment on
that one
please okay so i guess in terms of
priorities
um over um the corporate plan we've
talked about the time inside of it and
actually um it may be better to have the
audit later because the internal uh
internal look that we're taking in face
of covet 19
so that's why the priorities are
different in terms of what
that involves it looks at the process
from the transformation program
and looking at how the process has been
put in place to ensure that appropriate
knowledge transfer is in place
appropriate systems are in place and
that everything's working
effectively from that point of view so
so in regards to it that is
quite a quite an important process
so are we talking that's what knowledge
management and transfer means
yes yeah okay are you happy with that
council head
well uh i'm not really to be honest uh
how can we
how can we decide what the knowledge
level is
if we haven't got a plan of priorities
it just seems to me that
the corporate plan and priorities seem
to have more significance
yeah um yeah well if i can
perhaps perhaps just add something i
mean i think one of the key risks we've
talked about
around the council in previous years is
around the loss of
knowledge when officers leave and that
and that you have had
quite high turnover as a result of
transformation um
and it was seen as a key risk to make
sure that when people leave there is a
process to ensure
um you know that information is still
retained within the council and that
you're able to carry on performing
services to to the level you expect so
you know we did see that as a fairly
high risk area
um the the corporate plan i i mean i
agree with the councillor it's an
important area we do need to audit it
but
um while it's going through a change
process
uh i'm not sure the audit is going to be
particularly valuable at the moment
we i think the timing would be better to
wait until officers have reviewed the
plan with members
and you're comfortable with your new
objectives and then we can audit that to
see whether
um that is being achieved appropriately
it's it's i don't know how much value
you'd get from us doing an audit right
in the middle of that happening
okay i'm satisfied with that chairman
thank you okay good good good
okay so we're moving on then um members
to um ms donnelly presenting community
safety audit
please um yeah thank you
i will start at page 29.
so this audit and reviewed the council's
governance of the community safety plan
and the work card out against its
overarching priorities um
that's decided at the start of funding
1920
and the action plans resulting from
those priorities
and then monitoring and completion of
those
we find that there was a comprehensive
community safety strategic assessment
undertaken and which then identified the
five priorities for 1920
and that was done with each of the
strategic partners so the
essex place county council and nhs
ethics probation and the fire and rescue
service
we find that each of the priorities had
an action plan
and had owners and time scales for
completion
and we also found that the overview and
scrutiny committee meeting as the
crime and disorder committee reviewed
progress against the action plans
and the monthly task group is in place
to help progress those actions
we also um noted that there were key
roles and responsibilities for community
safety was in place
and a community safety partnership
manager is in phase who works across
both malden and chelmsford
councils we've noted a couple of things
for improvement
and the first of those is monitoring
energy of the finances around the
community
and safety partnership so what that's i
think
it's about 12 000 pounds but there's
just not that um
a review really of the finances it's
more obviously focused on
the actual delivery of the action plans
so we've recommended that there
would be a more regular review of how
the finances are used
and i think that's been agreed they'll
be taken forward to the overview and
scrutiny committee schedule
for october and also
we find that some of the action plans
didn't provide enough information on
whether or not they were
going to be completed to agree time
frames and they weren't always kept up
to date
so again that will be revised and
updated for the october meeting
and those are the the key things that
came from the community safety review
there's any questions okay thank you mr
donnelly i'm
i i would like if if um spencer clark is
here to
get him to just comment on the findings
of the report and the recommendations
um is spencer clark here
yes he is yes would you like to come in
there spencer thank you
thank you um yeah thank you uh i say
i've spoken to
emma on a number of occasions regarding
this audit and
chris andre who actually conducted the
audit for bdo
yes i've provided the management
response to uh the recommendations
uh on on the audit uh one one being
about the
responsible priorities group not meeting
uh four times a year in accordance with
um terms of reference
um so there were a number of uh it's
quite an unusual for the last
uh year or so uh because we've had a
number of factors such as
the restructure of malden district
council and transformation
we had the chair of the rag who was the
chief inspector leaving for another
police force
going to the met at quite short notice
um but what we what we've
also been looking at doing is uh um
migrating over to
uh one moulding district which has been
to members and
uh is still um um that's been sort of
paused by covid currently so i think
that's something which the directors are
looking at at the moment to see how we
can progress that
um we have already got a new date in the
diary for next rag meeting which is the
8th of september
so we'll be meeting on the 8th of
september again so that uh we'll have
that recommendation
um completed um in order for the october
overview and scrutiny committee as mr
donnelly said
um so we'll continue to meet quarterly
until there's
any substantive changes in
how the community safety partnership
will work in the future um with regards
to budget monitoring
um so we we receive a sum of money each
year from the police commissioner
it's around about um 14 000 pounds but
some of that is top sliced for domestic
homicide reviews so we only actually
receive
12 527 so whilst we
provide an annual report to the
police fire and crime commissioner on
the spend because
that's a condition of the grant and
these were provided to bdo we haven't
actually
reported to the actual responsible
authorities group so that's something
which
we'll pick up on um i've asked a staff
member responsible for this to
change our action plans so that we have
a
red and amber green rating in the action
plans now
but also uh a profile spend and where we
are as spend
so things are delayed throughout the
year say for example
uh during the covet crisis it's made us
a bit of a struggle to do face-to-face
communications so the
popular sort of interventions we've done
with school trailer and like crucial
crew
has had to be cancelled and be delivered
later on in this year
so most of those things we're picking up
on and uh
we'll hope to have those rectified by
the 8th of september
so for the next overview and scrutiny
committee when we've got a date for that
in october we'll be able to present to
members
thank you very much ms clark for that um
berna have we got members that wish to
speak
yes gentlemen we've got cancer channer
and then counselor heard
okay counselor channel
uh thank thank you madam chairman
it's been answered partly and i see you
see spencer's rise smile there
i have to say i was a little surprised
to read about the finances and not and i
know it might be considered a small
amount
but really what i'm seeking is spencer's
answered it partly but
assurances about the plans put in place
to show
to ensure there is the financial
monitoring because it very much is
important
you know very important aspect of this
and i was quite
surprised to see what looked at me a
year's gap almost in rag meetings and i
acknowledge all the um uh sort of
issues that might have come about but a
number of us have been having to engage
in zoom meetings and everything and
meeting face-to-face and i got the
impression because the
reference is the hubs meeting i know was
it monthly or something because i can't
get the paper up
it seemed to feel it seemed to be the
way i read it but
because that was happening that was it
that was okay but what's important is
about the member involvement
and i want assurances given on that side
really that members will
be given because there was reference to
not really enough being done in the
committee environment perhaps that's how
i read it in the statement may that was
my interpretation of it
and i have to be frank i've often
wondered myself where some of the work
has gone because
when we had a community safe uh
community services committee
i'm very much aware of stuff and without
scrutiny so
having read that report i'm just scared
that perhaps some things have gone
through the civ a bit and not enough in
the member environment
regarding certainly the finance aspect
spencer do you want to comment on that
yeah yeah i mean it's a very very good
point so
uh yes uh we we have not met as
regularly as we should have done
uh in light of our terms of reference
we have i certainly met twice a year for
crime and disorder committee
so members have been able to scrutinize
the work of the partnership
um what what i have said i mean as
councillor
channel pointed out he's a relatively
small sum of money
and that money has generally uh
paid for the officer role the community
safety development officer role
so what we've what we've agreed as part
of the recommendation
is we'll also include the molden
district council
budget for events so that's where it's
spent on
things like crucial crew and
interventions we do with
older persons so we'll highlight a bit
more than just the
grant that we receive uh so that'll be
more transparent for members to
to look at um and uh also we'll
whilst we have the the hub in place
which has been in place for
well over well over 18 months now
so that that means that myself and
claire the team member actually
co-located with the police
every day so uh but that's not the
reason why we shouldn't
also have the terms of reference agreed
with the four times a year meetings
so we'll rectify that as i said i put a
date in the diary for the 8th of
september
and whilst we still consider um the one
moulder district which is
still for consideration we'll continue
to meet on a quarterly basis
thank you are you happy with that
response counselor channel
well may i just come back on something
madam chairman yes yes i i do accept
that response but i would say
even that's a relatively small sum of
money and i appreciate you do a report
to the police fire
and crime commissioner i would think
also he would want to know
that there is proper sort of overview by
members or appropriate bodies to ensure
the finances i appreciate what you said
about staffing resources and everything
but he would like to know i think that
you know is being audited and of course
that's a role for
the district council the ovarian
scrutiny committee and it was quite
clear
the open scrutiny committee might have
met and looked at things but actually it
didn't really look
at the finances in sufficient detail i
think what you've explained that will
now happen
but i do think just to ensure because
let's face it
through the police crime police foreign
crime commissioner
maybe a small amount but we won't want
to see anything that might let's put it
this way jeopardize any future funding
coming from that source i would imagine
thank you spencer
you've noted that yeah you no further
comment on that yeah
yeah okay um counselor heard i think was
it you want you to speak as well
yes please thank you thank you madam
chairman uh
the question that i hope is this is the
right forum for that
um is that i've asked several years ago
uh about some signs which tell the
public
how to get to the police station and
they were due
to be put in uh wants road
uh in warwick crescent to actually tell
people where the police station was
and also can i have an update on the
progress
could have an update the on the progress
of putting the emergency telephone
into the council offices um which again
should have been done
many years ago um i keep on asking this
uh i think that it is an issue that we
haven't
had an overview and scrutiny meeting
for far too long indeed we haven't even
got an overview and scrutiny committee
at the moment
but what i'd like to know is what are we
doing about those community safety
measures please
okay and it's not really part of this
rematch but um
spencer could answer those queries
i certainly can chair um uh you're quite
right
uh councillor heard um i do recall
probably
two and a half years ago this discussion
was made in the town council offices
um it has been raid raised recently um
the chief inspector who's now
uh in place chief inspector steve scott
haynes
has taken this up he has provided
photographs of uh where the location of
the phone
should be going and that's been passed
on
to his uh team at headquarters now
and copied to frank brit who looks after
our um
side of things and director richard
holmes so
they've had a copy of that now uh he's
escalating it with his resources team to
get that phone in place so hopefully
we should be seeing that soon i'll have
to remind the police about the
advisory signs to location because i'm
sure
if the phone was overlooked it's likely
that the signage was also overlooked
it is really a policing matter but i
will raise that with
the chief inspector since he's already
on the case with regards to the location
of the phone
okay thank you thank you mr clark um
any berna any other member want to raise
a question
no not at the moment chairman okay good
so we could move on to
workforce management um which is emma
donnelly again
please yep and that's on page 43.
so obviously as we discussed this was
looking specifically at the recruitment
processes
and the processes and procedures in
place and we
have given it a substantial on design
and medium on
operational effectiveness because we
found there were strong policies
procedures
in place and checklists for all stage of
the recruitment process
and there's a workforce development
strategy in place which reflects
and the corporate priorities and the hr
priorities
and hr staff were suitably qualified and
trained
and we noted one medium and two long
recommendations
the medium recommendation relates to the
development of a hr
kpi dashboard so that will be looking at
things like time to recruit
and then specifically breaking down so
and time to get back to candidates
how long on dbs chicks were dbs checks
for example may take
but also other parts of the the hr um
service i think that's currently under
development i think it was due to be
developed
and by july the two low recommendations
were just arrived from
housekeeping so ensuring that if each
e training was done that there was and
that was the results of that was sort of
centrally so that
we can check compliance and also where
applicants and making sure that all
qualifications for applicants are kept
on file and if there's
um maybe a waiver in place because they
they know their experience outweighs
whatever qualification they maybe didn't
have
that that should be noted somewhere but
in the exceptions we find that
that was appropriate so it's just been
housekeeping on and making sure things
are noted in the fine
and that's it thank you thank you thank
you
thank you um we also have
uh an officer annette cardi who
um would she be um so
kind of to comment on some of the
findings on this report thank you
hello hello
so yes as zimmer says
there was two housekeeping requirements
which were put into place straight away
so
we have now changed the policy
regarding the documents we get from
recruitment
and the last one which was the
kpis we have developed
some kpis around the time it takes to
recruit
around leavers and starters and that
that is going to pga um
from i think the next meeting um
and then we will develop that further
as as we evolve
thank you um so berna are there any
members that wish to raise
a question on this report yes counselor
nun
indicated at the beginning he would like
okay thank you councillor
yes thank you very much chair there
seems to be
a bit of a contradiction here if we turn
to page 46
uh and we bear in mind the comments that
miss donnelly's already made that there
are strong policies and procedures in
place
um but at the same time we seem to have
two
omissions in relation to a file audit on
qualifications
clearly if there are strong policies and
procedures in place they're not being
adhered to
and i think this is something that needs
to be passed back to resources
because clearly we need a tighter
recruitment
procedure and policy that actually
ensures that
the evidence is on file quite often
a lack of evidence doesn't mean that it
hasn't happened
it's just a lack of evidence but at the
same time it needs to be there
so that's page 46 and on page 47
given the the reorganization uh that
the district council has been through
and bearing in mind this
impacts on retention i think what we
actually need as a kpi
is some kind of measure that relates to
well-being or
staff engagement thank you very much
okay thank you annette would you like to
comment on those points
so on page 46 it was
actually um two cases out of the 15 that
were tested
um and it was related to
some evidence around a qualification for
somebody
that had actually been in work for a
number of years so it was around their
their gcse's row levels
so it um they couldn't find those
qualifications
so the relevance of it to her skills
when she was recruited we tested those
skills in other ways
so we've just amended our policies we're
quite right
um we do need to follow those but to
ensure
that where those are the case then we
actually
have different ways that we can measure
for those
uh skills those numeracy and writing
skills
because it would be unfair to penalize
people who
are maybe quite a few years from their o
levels or gcses that can't actually
find those documents the second point
around the kpis
that is certainly something we can look
at measuring
employee satisfaction in future we do do
a survey of that and we have got the
full results of that
so we could bring out um some kpis
around that
okay thank you uh council and are you
happy with that response
um partly chairman um any admission
on a file audit is is not good
uh whether it's historic or otherwise so
it does need to be looked at there's
always a way of
verifying qualifications uh in terms of
the kpis
this is not necessarily about engage
this is not necessarily
about the areas that uh have been
mentioned by ms cardi
um it's actually about well-being and
it's about
well-being linked to engagement uh
so i think those areas need to be looked
at
yes sorry that is actually in in the
survey around well-being as well so yes
we will link
we will look at that thank you very much
um berna have we got any other members
wishing to speak
uh counselor fluker would like to ask a
question
yeah thank you chairman i i just wanted
to go back to this staff survey because
for a long while we used to have a staff
survey and the results were reported to
the members
but we also used to have a staff forum
which was a selection of staff members
chosen by the staff
and a member used to attend as well and
that used to be
really successful and the work around
the staff
survey we changed it completely and we
actually won a sit for award
uh for the work that the council did now
you know i'd like to think going forward
that perhaps you or the vice chairman of
this committee
might just pick that up and see if we
can't run with that again
because i think it it worked very well
for the council and it would be very
very interesting
post transformation uh what that would
look like
thank you all right thank you for that
council fluker
um berna was there anyone else no
chairman
okay so members will roof to the
recommendations there are three
recommendations on the three reports
that we've been
uh debating um so are you happy to
accept
those recommendations can i have a
second to please
i'll second that madam chairman okay
thank you councillor janna
so we move on to um
do we really need to take a vote um
well if members are happy i think
generally members are happy with it so i
don't think we need to take a vote
um so we've done the external report so
we move on to
agenda item a code of corporate
governance report um
which is uh mr hughes cheryl hughes to
take
present this report please hello members
hello
and so the corporate governance document
hadn't been refreshed since 2009 so this
is a good housekeeping exercise to
update it
um and given that revised measures of
good governance have since been
introduced
by cypher we've kind of brought it all
in line really
um the document should highlight our
work in principles around governance and
underpin annual governance review and
giving a framework for annual governance
statement in line with the sip for
guidance
the code makes a link to policies and
working practices that underpin
and demonstrate good governance and our
framework at molden district council
and the covering report provided
recommends
this committee adopt the draft code of
corporate governance as provided at
appendix a which is page 79-83
use this as a framework to monitor
progress of the annual governance
statement actions
and review governance actions through a
quarterly report in terms of the
effectiveness of this code
so um that's my introduction thank you
thank you thank you very much
um so berna have we got any members that
wish to speak
on this uh yes counselor stamp counselor
stamp
uh yes thank you chairman and forgive me
i haven't read everything
and that is my bag i'm really sorry i've
been absolutely snowed under and had
really bad
technical issues recently but does it
cover in here
um on our governance about working
groups
and inclusion is it that detailed how
would we go about trying to amend
something like that to make this council
all inclusive so for example when
members are
putting together groups so you can have
more of a
joint cohesive council rather than
a dominant council is that would that be
covered in this one misuse please
um no so the code largely focuses on the
mechanisms that we've got in place so
you know um what our um structure is
uh what um working practices there are
um the that kind of level of detail is
almost
a um decisions that are
that are made underneath that if that
makes sense
but it's part of our story chairman it
but it's part of our constitution isn't
it
so it can be mended can it
you know as members would just decide
that's that that's the level of detail
that it would be that would be a member
decision
chairman can i do please allow me how do
we go about that though so this to me is
this sort of committee where we should
be able to ask these sorts of questions
how would we go about trying to change
that do i have to put a motion to
counsel
or what um i'm not
absolutely sure what you're trying to
say
councillor stem i'm trying to ascertain
chairman how we can make
a membership on working groups to be
more balanced to get the information to
participate
in committees to have the knowledge that
gives us the background information to
make more informed comments
and choices chairman okay well i don't
think that's
part of this as as cheryl hughes has
explained i mean this is about
how we go about governing our
way of working so it's not quite the
same
um i would suggest that this needs to be
something that's brought to council
possibly
yes that's what i did ask him to council
i'm more than happy
to take it i mean it's a leadership um
issue
i'd say so you probably need to speak to
the leader to discuss that i don't know
whether you've got any comments on that
counselor fluker
councillor fluka have you got any
comments on this yeah thank you chairman
i mean
working groups report back to to uh
whoever sets them up so
any any information that comes back from
working groups either goes back to what
our sales program or main committee or
council so all the information goes back
to to that you know through that route
so
as councillor stamp no she sits on some
of the working groups they don't make
decisions they just look at
overall policy and come back and make
recommendations to to whoever sets them
up
so i don't think anyone's really
excluded um but of course i'm more than
happy to meet with them and discuss it
in depth if she wishes but
she'll know that she is on some working
groups herself thank you
okay thank you very much all right well
we've taken your
points on board council stamp so can we
have we got any other members that wish
to raise anything on this
on this agenda item bernard yes chairman
cancerous
swain heard and jarvis and councillor
morris has asked if you can ask a
question as well
well councillor morris hasn't asked
prior to the meeting has he's not a
member of this committee i did tell him
before
so i can't allow that i'm sorry
councillor morris
okay so that's okay that's
i did actually put an email in to all
committee chairs to explain that i would
be requiring to speak during a meeting
when i needed to
i've done that quite some time ago i
don't think i i've seen that counselor
morris
i mean i did say to you before that if
you wanted to raise something
you needed to advise us before the start
of the meeting
that you wanted to speak and you haven't
done that
i'm sorry about it you haven't done that
this time
so i wouldn't have tech problems just
like
a lot of the other counsellors have
councillor durham said
sick let you speak problems
time but i think you know i did make the
point previously
that you needed to do this so i'd like
to
carry on with the meeting we have
councillor swain who wishes to speak
i'd like my question please are you
refusing my question
i am they're lying
procedure counselor morris i'd like to
listen to councillors
please commitment technical values
integrity spat my coffee out on that one
we've got bullying going on in this uh
council bad bullying
we've got homophobia we've got fresh
it's got nothing to do
with what
that's going to be discussed as you know
and it's not for discussion at this
particular committee councillor morris
shayman i ask you to mute yourself so
that councillor swain can speak please
yeah well you could ask but as you
refuse
me maybe i will refuse you good for the
goose good for the gander how about that
thank you can we can we hear from cancer
swain please please
refuse maybe i'm a little bit better
than you cronies
thank you madam chairman i recall last
year that the
annual apologies for that interruption
people councillor swain
sorry well last year the annual
governor's statement was presented by
mr mate as this apology
you do not need to apologize for me
elaine i
am not i'm apologize to speak and i
deserve i have a right
to speak the only reason that i have
stopped speaking
and turn my microphone and camera off is
because i have respect
for councillor swain there are other
councillors
in this meeting that have brought the
council in to disrepute
and you guys are suffering them now i'll
turn my microphone
and camera off out of respect to
councillor swain
and the other councillors that aren't
corrupt that are in this meeting
but it will not be for the corrupt ones
in this meeting or the one and shame on
you elaine
i thought you was better than that i
simply wanted to ask a question
thank you councillor morris thank you
well i thank counselor morris for that
backhanded compliment
um the first point is
and i mentioned about the annual
government statement being presented by
the
section 151 officer last time and
um on page 80 where it talks about the
monitoring officer
and says he or she is responsible for
seeing agreed procedures are followed
so i assume that we're talking basically
about um
procedures in handling financial matters
uh in the council um
a second point a minor point on page 83
refers to the um balanced scorecard
that is being used to um inform senior
on senior managers performance uh
perhaps we could have some explanation
of what a balanced
balance score card is my
third point which is um probably more
significant really
um is it concerns the level of detail
um that is conveyed and under this new
system of reporting on performance that
misuses um presented and worked on
and i feel it still doesn't actually
provide sufficient information for
members
to be to be able to criticize and help
and
comment um and i think it would be
helpful if it was expanded to include a
little bit more information
about what it is that tier two managers
are being asked to do in their
um so that members can appreciate any
problems and and difficulties
and perhaps help to resolve them
thank you ramsey thank you cancer screen
um
i know that um miss hughes is looking at
revising
a lot of the performance reports but
perhaps you'd like to comment on
your points yep so
on the first point um it's all
governance procedures that are covered
in this and
all governance procedures that the
monitoring officer has responsibility
for
um the second point on the balance
scorecard
um that's probably actually what you're
alluding to in that that's our internal
performance
document um where we look at that um
service based level data and our service
performance
um it is something that's still in
development and actually the corporate
governance working group
when we met earlier this week and saw
the detail of that because we were
talking about the mechanism for how we
um report where there's um amber flags
for
non-delivery how we report that back up
potentially to
this committee so that was something
that was discussed
um at corporate governance working group
and obviously we'll come back to council
once that's developed a bit further
um so hopefully that gives you a bit of
reassurance and answers that question
are you happy with that counselor swain
um yes well i hope that will
will help um members to appreciate um
uh where there are difficulties and um
they can perhaps contribute to resolving
them
thank you well most performance reports
will come back to this committee so
you know if we're not happy with the
information we can always raise it then
um any other member yes good chairman
cancer hurt
yes sorry counselor
counselor
well we had councillor jarvis as well i
believe perhaps council jarvis could
come in
thank you chairman um i just wanted to
pick up on oh first of all i think it is
obviously good that we're
seeing that new code i think the fact
that we're going to get regular
reports on a quarterly basis to this
committee is also something we've been
asking for
because obviously governance is uh
clearly part of this community
so i think we should be pleased that
we're going to get regular reports
i think the point about
putting work people on working groups
you know those sort of issues
making changes that council stan
mentioned i think one of the problems is
that uh you know
there does seem to be a lack of the
right sort of
working groups where these matters can
be discussed perhaps
and in fact we've also you know perhaps
on internal audit you know
there are issues there where working
groups if they existed where they could
discuss things
uh and better understand things could
then put better recommendations forward
to committees there is a corporate
governance working group it doesn't
report to this committee which i do find
slightly odd i have to say
but there is one and certainly any
issues such as
membership of working groups as a point
of principle i would have thought
at the moment in the current structure
the corporate governance working group
is
exactly the working group where that
item should be debated
discussed and then if recommendation is
considered appropriate
that could go straight to council in the
current arrangement
so i just wanted to uh make that point
that i think
there is one of the corporate governance
working group that exists that could
cater
for the for the points that were made by
councillors stamp
but also i think some organization of
working groups that would then better
serve this committee
is also something we should look at in
terms of performance
internal audit external audit and
governance in general thank you chairman
thank you councillor jarvis well it is
in our remit
to um set up working group so
if members think that we should have
something
along those lines then it's worth
thinking about for
perhaps a recommendation to a future
meeting
so we we could discuss that separately
uh councillor jarvis
um and thank you for doing it i'd be
very happy to discuss that with you
perhaps come back with a more formal
recommendation at the next meeting
thank you okay thank you councillor
jarvis have we got councillor heard back
yet bernie yes we have
yes councillor heard yes thank you thank
you madam chairman
uh i really want i'm looking at uh
appendix a
and this is on uh page 79
and there are several references um to
the constitution
and the very first thing it says is the
council expects the authority's
leadership
to create a climate of openness support
and respect and to uphold the council's
values
now i don't think that's happening at
the moment and
this has been evidenced uh by the fact
that although
uh as councillor stampers said these
working groups are
existing uh the the independent members
which make up
something like 45 percent of the council
um
are not well i i guess the word is
excluded because we are not being
allowed on some of these working groups
we keep hearing about promises but it
isn't
uh it isn't forthcoming fully
and the second thing is the standards of
conduct and personal behaviour expected
of members and staff
is set out in the employee code of
conduct and this doesn't seem
this seems to me nothing more than lip
service
and if we just go over the page we're
talking about the the council's standing
orders and financial regulations
uh to ensure that members and employees
of this authority are not
influenced by prejudice bias or
conflicts of interest
when we know that that is not the case
at the moment
so i'm not really happy to
although i'm happy to adopt this because
i think i do comply
uh uh with those regulations i'm not
sure that that is the case
uh and this needs to be addressed
okay thank you council um i don't know
whether you
did hear what council drivers had to say
about setting up perhaps
a separate working group or that uh
council stamps points would go
possibly to corporate governance well
i've got
i've got a lot of time for councillor
jarvis but um
as i say i speak as the sole member on
the
corporate governance working group the
sole member of the independent group
yes all right okay well i think your
point is is taken thank you council
ahead
um any other members bernard no
chairman okay then we're moving members
to the recommendations there are three
recommendations the first one to adopt
the
code draft code of corporate conduct
the performance governance and audit
committee
used the framework as a way to monitor
progress on actions set out in the
annual governance statement
and that a quarterly report of annual
governance actions is
provided to this committee for review
oh um have i got a seconder to those
approving those recommendations please
so every all members are happy to go
with that
yes now i will i will abstain from this
because i think it's lip service and i
don't think it's
we're doing what it says tonight and i
agree can we have a vote please
so then i think we need to yes i was
going to suggest um
council stamp that in fact we have a
vote then burner
if you can take um everyone in turn
okay and i'm always first so minus four
four and councillor beal i note that
he's now in attendance councillor beal
i'm here thank you we're voting on the
recommendations counselor bill there are
three recommendations
um are members happy to take those on
block or is there a particular part that
you're not happy with
not on block please chairman can we do
each individual one please chair
all right so we take little one then and
um
i'm for that um counselor bill
i'm going okay
okay carry on burner sorry cass
councillor channel has left the meeting
um councillor durham is is not voting
because his
i.t is not secure councillor fluke was
that the meeting
councilor harker agree recommendation
um i will abstain
counselor jarvis four
councillor keys is not here
councillor none against
cancer schemes apologies cancer stamp
against
castle stilts
not expected four four
okay chairman that's four four four
the first recommendation for against
this first recommendation and
two abstentions
sorry burner can you say that again
we've got four
for the first recommendation okay we've
got four against
and we've got two abstentions okay so i
can cast the
um vote to say we adopt it we go
for okay so that's carried
that that's carried so the next two
recommendations
um we'll take individually um the next
one
is um to use this framework as a way to
monitor the progress of actions
in the annual governance statement and
i'm for that
thank you and councillor biel
against
cancer harker agreed a recommendation
that's the heard
uh yes i will support i will support
this
thank you councillor jarvis
for constant none
you're still there are you muted
counsellor nun
sorry berna yes abstain abstain
thank you and councillor stamp
full thank you councillor stilts
epstein
council swain i'm abstain
and counsel mrs thompson
again four for the recommendation
so that's six for the recommendation one
against
three abstentions okay so that's passed
um so the next one is a quarterly report
on to this committee so i'm for that
thank you councillor bill
agree the recommendation thank you
cancer heard
four jarvis
counselor nun abstain
stamp
mrs thompson paul
thank you that's nine four none against
one abstention
okay so that's part so thank you very
much members um so we move on to the
next item which
is the annual corporate governance
statement report
now as most many members who were on
this committee before will know
we normally had this with this statement
of account so this is a change
um so um i presume it's cheryl
who's going to present this to the
committee yes
thank you yeah so um this is the annual
governance statement this year and as
you mentioned has had a change to
template
um this is to reflect it for best
practice advice
um and that's provided as an appendix to
the report
page 87 to 96.
it's provided as a separate item to the
statement of accounts to highlight the
importance of governance and our
governance arrangements
in the 1920 financial year and the
template's also been updated to comment
on molden district council's position
against the seven principles of good
governance
which are identified by sipfer and
solace in 2016.
the new format also provides an action
table for the next year
with recommendations to track quarterly
at performance governance and audit
committee
and give a tangible means to review
governance matters
additionally i would just like to note
that as this report was commenting on
governance arrangements until march
2020 we haven't mentioned and reviewed
on detail
covid governance arrangements but this
would be covered next year
the covered ring report recommends that
this committee
approve the annual governance statement
appendix a
um agree to monitor the progress of the
action plan
um and agree a quarterly report and
those two recommendations are actually
um repeated in the motion that's just
been carried
just to know um and through this
mechanism
that the committee are assured of
government's arrangements
and monitoring thank you
thank you miss hughes um berna have we
got any members that wish to speak on
this
no chairman so members then
are we happy to take these three
recommendations
on block yes agreed
um
[Music]
apologies for the interruption chair
we're seeing agreed by ascent
yes okay yes yes
chairman councillor swain's got a
question chairman oh sorry sorry
okay sorry chance this way
did you go on to the chat counselor
swain yes
it takes time doing that doesn't it yeah
well that's the trouble yeah okay
okay we'll allow you to come forward um
clarification of few points has been
mentioned
made mention here something new that
i've come across not come across before
this project
management office um we presumably don't
have a project management office sir
so i'd like to know how that operates um
i do find actually some difficulty with
this point as to who
wrote it um certain sections
um seem to be written by bdo and some uh
it's not clear which sections have been
written
actually by um officers um
uh the balance support scorecard has
been mentioned um there is a
a comment there about peer review of
scrutiny arrangements
but wonder how that is carried out
um and then as the groups as
groups are consulted and i wonder what
the arrangements are oversight of those
groups that are consulted on this um
amounts to on page 92 that is
thank you um ms hughes sorry could you
comment quickly on those
yeah most of them quickly the page 92
i'll have to just look into in a bit
more detail
um the pmo we do have a projects
administrator post
in the structure which sits within my
team
um but the pmo is sort of a virtual team
in that several officers support that
we have a monthly project board with the
extended leadership team that's the
officers extended leadership team that
reviews projects
and gets updates on projects so that we
know things are running
effectively and we also have like a
corporate lessons learnt log
and missed opportunities log and all of
the things that go with a standard
project management office um the
introduction
and there's a section at the
introduction which is bdo's comment of
um our governance arrangements for the
last year
that's written by bdo that's taken from
their um
audit um report for the year um but the
rest of the report is officer written
um it's officer comment on our
governance arrangements
and that sort of underpins the detail on
that
um the peer review is something that's
available to us through
things like the lga um it's just
a comment on things that are available
to us it's not necessarily something
that's in practice yet and that might be
something that comes out in the action
plan
now 92 could you be more specific about
the line that you're referencing on that
one
i'm afraid no it talks about groups as a
consultant
um and arrangements and oversight of
them
um i'm afraid i haven't made a note of
the range of the extent of the
consultation but
oh so this is the ensuring openness and
stakeholder engagement section
so this is just to say that we do
consult and it does have
um a list of some so it's got like um
parish clerks
forums and different forums and it's um
it's just about how we consult with the
public
right thank you are you happy with that
council
i think i'm right in saying that yes
this statement is overseen by the
external auditor
as well so i believe chris might be able
to provide more detail but i believe
that
we adopt it and then the external
auditor reviews it as part of their
review of the statement of account
yeah yes that's correct yeah
good can i just uh
since we voted on it can i
um are we saying that we officially
um voted on that
well you agreed by ascent yeah before we
let the cancer swing in
um i think really we need to have this
hand thing sorted out but anyway
um disrupts matters all right well
if we can just note then that counselor
swain came in after the vote
and he's abstained it won't actually
change the overall vote no no
i will notice no that's fair enough um
so the next item
any other items of business that the
chairman of the committee decides are
urgent i have none
so members at 2 30
who i'll close the meeting and thank you
very much for attending
and have a good afternoon